[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم عشرون عاما مرت على احتلال
العراق في عام 2003 وقد تكون تلك الاعوام
ارضا خصبه لسيره من التيه التي عاشتها
البلاد بعد ان اصبحت ملعبا للمشاريع
الاقليميه والدوليه وجحيما لاهلها الذين
خرجوا من نير الديكتاتوريه والاستبداد
ووقعوا في براثن النهب والفساد والاقتتال
الاهلي والحروب الطائفيه شكلت انتفاضه
تشرين العراقيه في عام 2019 لحظه احتجاج
كبرى على طبقه السياسيه الحاكمه ومشاريعها
وحاله الضياع والعبث التي تعيشها واحده من
اغنى البلدان العربيه نفطا وماء وثروه
بشريه تضج بالعقول والطاقات المهدره بين
التهميش والتهجير وصراع الولاءات لكن ثمه
بصيص من امل تلمسته في زياره الاخيره
للعراق رئيس وزراء جديد لاول مره من عراقي
الداخل وسيره خاليه كما يظهر من الفساد
واثار الدم ورغم للطبقه السياسيه التي
تولت الامر طوال عقدين الا انه يرفع
شعارات حاده وجاده تجاه الفساد
والمحسوبيات وهدر المقدرات تناولت معه كل
هذه التحديات الصعبه وبرنامج عمله الذي
بدا للتو في مشوار تحقيق ما عبر عنه الغضب
الشعبي العراقي في الاعوام الماضيه محمد
الشياع السوداني رئيس الوزراء الذي استقال
من ائتلاف دوله القانون واسست تيار
الفراتي ورشحه الاطار التنسيقي رئيسا
توافقيا للحكومه في البلاد المهندس الذي
ينتظر منه تعليق بارقه من امل في نفق
العراق الطويل ضيفي في هذه الحلقه والحلقه
التي تليها فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
سعداء جدا بوجودنا في بغداد ونحن اسعد
وبلقائك وبهذا الوقت
يبدو انه يمر يحاول ان يخرج من عنق
الزجاجه لا نعلم ان كان قد خرج او في صدد
المحاوله ما هي اولويات رئيس الوزراء
العراقي اليوم الاولويات الملحه وقد
استمعنا لاكثر من حديث منك عن الفساد وعن
الملفات الداخليه بشكل قوي بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لكم ولمشاهدي قناتكم
كريمه واهلا وسهلا بكم في هذا اللقاء اهلا
بكم في بغداد
الحمد لله بكل ثقه العراق خرج من عرقه
زجاجه العراق
اليوم
متعافي متصالح مع نفسه حقق نصر على
الارهاب
بملحمه تاريخيه من كل ابناء الشعب العراقي
كلهم
وقفوا في خندق واحد
[موسيقى]
هذه العمليه السياسيه ايضا تشهد
بناءات ايجابيه وفهم من قبل الجميع لاهميه
تعزيزها ومعالجه واصلاح ما يحصل فيها من
ثغرات
الحكومه
حكومتي هي السادسه بعد التغيير
منذ عام 2003
المتحدث جزء من المنظومه
السياسيه الاداريه من 2003 ولحد الان
وبالتالي
المسلسل واضح امامي للمرحله السابقه واضح
بسلبياته وايجابيات
يفترض رؤيه هذه الحكومه اولويات هذه
الحكومه تاخذ بنظر الاعتبار هذه الخلفيه
وعلى هذه الاساس وضعنا
اولوياتنا لانها تمثل تطلعات واعمال
المواطنين اليوم عندنا مشكله الفقر اليوم
عندنا مشكله البطاله اليوم عندنا مشكله
سوء الخدمات لازم نحسن الخدمات اليوم
عندنا مشكله الفساد المستشري هذه السلبيات
اليوم عندنا ضروره
لاصلاحات اقتصاديه لا يمكن بعد نتاخر
بالاصلاحات الاقتصاديه يجوز قبل كانوا
يتكلمون الحكومات من ناحيه ومن باب
الكماليه انه يقول لك اصلاحات وكذا ومعتمد
على النفط اسعاره مرتفعه ويغطي انفاقات لا
اليوم لازم يصير اصلاح ما طبيعه الاصلاحات
الاقتصاديه التي يهدف لها رئيس الوزراء
العراقي اولا لا يمكن ان ابقى متفرجا على
الغاز يحرق الغاز المصاحب لانتاج النفط
وانا استورد غاز
بقيمه ثمانيه تريليون دينار بالسنه
جريمه
طيب انا بلد نفطي واستورد المشتقات
النفطيه بحدود اثنين الى ثلاثه تريليون
بالسنه انا بلد واقتصادي قائم فقط على
اسعار النفط ارتفعت اسعار النفط عندنا
موازنه عندنا رواتب عندنا خدمات عندنا
موازنه تشغيليه انخفضت اسعار النفط نحتار
شلون نجمع رواتب الموظفين والمتقاعدين
امام هذا المشهد ما تقدر تقول خل انتظر
فتره لازم عندك برنامج للاصلاح يتضمن هذا
البرنامج تفعيل القطاعات العراق القطاع
الغاز اولا نقلل من هذا هذا هدر انت مريت
تحرق غاز اللي هو اموال
وبنفس الوقت تاخذ من الاموال اللي عندك
تستورد غاز تخسر مرتين مرتين
كنت تستفاد مما لديك من ثروات طبيعيه ترى
العراق مو فقط بلد نفطي ممكن يكون بلد
زراعي وممكن يكون بلا صناعي لدينا من
المعادن والثروات الطبيعيه والبنى التعتيه
الشيء الذي يمكننا من ان نكون بلا صناعي
هذه كلها مقومات حتى تنهض بالاقتصاد وتنوع
من مصادر الدخل هذا هو اللي يعني به
الاصلاح الحقيقي هذا طبعا يجب ان يقوم على
رؤيه وفلسفه جديده مو رؤيه النظام
الاشتراكي الذي كان سائدا منذ النظام
السابق لا رؤيه القطاع الخاص هو القطاع
الذي ممكن ان يقود عمليه الاصلاح هل تمت
فرص للقطاع الخاصه العراقي او او الدولي
او العربي الاستثمارات في عهد السوداني
اكثر بلد استطيع القول وبكل ثقه اكثر بلد
في فرص واعده للاستثمار هو العراق ما
طبيعه الفرص المطروحه في كل قطاع انت
تتكلم عن اربعين مليون نسمه
نفوس العراقي
هذا العدد يحتاج من المستلزمات المعيشيه
والحياتيه والغذائيه اللي تمكنه من نشوء
صناعات في كل القطاعات احنا وفق احصائيه
وزاره التخطيط نستورد سنويا سلع
منتجات بما يقارب خمسين مليار دولار طيب
تدور المساله حول فكره الفساد دوله الرئيس
بمعنى انه الفساد من الواضح انه يؤدي الى
تاكل الثروات العراقيه يؤدي الى افقار
المواطنين يؤدي الى ضعاف الفرص جميعا ومن
الواضح ان هناك قوه كبرى اساسيه في المشهد
السياسي العراقي كانت الفاسده مفسده طوال
الفتره الماضي ويقال ان السوداني ربما
كريس وزراء لا يستطيع مواجهته لانه جزء
منها
التحدي الذي يواجه الدوله العراقيه هو
الفساد مو داعش داعش انتهى
الان مطارد في الصحاري في الكهوف في
الجبال ماكو داعش يمسك ارض الان كتحدي
للدوله الفساد لان الفساد يعطل الخدمات
يعطل تنفيذ هذه الاولويات اللي ذكرتها
الاقتصادي ولا المشاريع والاستثمارات
احسنت والخدمات والبطاله
الفساد الجزء الاكبر منه محمي من الواجهات
السياسيه او رسميه
وهذا هو التحدي راح تقول لي المرحله
السابقه هل كانت هناك اراده حقيقيه
لمكافحه الفساد للاسف اقول كلا لم تكون لم
تكن هناك اراده مو صعب مكافحه الفساد انا
وزير في حكومتين كحفحت الفساد في وزرتي ما
طبيعه الفساد
مو فقط يعني سعد القوه المهيمنه للاسف جزء
من عده فساد مجتمعي يعني اليوم الموظف
اللي
يبتز او ياخذ رشوه
السياسي الكبير ياخذ رشوه وياخذ عمولات
بمستويات يعني هذا الفساد الاخطر الفساد
الاكبر يعني احنا عندنا ايرادات
الايرادات الغير نفطيه ايرادات المنافذ
الضريبيه والقمر القسم الاكبر متورطين
فيها موظفين
ماكو حزب قاعد بمنفذ ويجيب لنفسه اكو موظف
يستغل العمليه وعدم وجود محاسبه ورده
وتشوفه يستولي على اموال
سرقه القرن هذا اللي انتشرت وسمعت بيها
هذه الضمانات ضريبيه سرقت بمقدار ثلاثه
تريليون وسبع مئه مليار دينار
هذي مو حذفيها حمايه فيها غطاء رسمي رسمي
حكومي
والان القضاء يتحدث مو انا قضاء يتحدث عن
وجود شبكه من كبار المسؤولين في الحكومه
السابقه
ساهموا بالتغطيه وتقديم التسهيلات لشبكه
من السراق استولت على هذه الاموال شنو راح
تسوي بهذا الاتجاه بحقه
سياسيين لك هذا هذه القضيه بالتحديد اذا
لم تكن فيها محاسبه
واسترداد للمال العام فاي حديث عن مكافحه
الفساد هذا عبث
وضحك على الذكور
لذلك منذ اليوم الاول انا كنت واضح وصريح
للراي العام ومع مجلس القضاء الذي يبذل
جهد استثنائي في هذه العمليه قلت لهم
بالتحديد
ايا كان المتورط
في هذه العمليه ايا كان مهما كان موقع او
صفته او قربه من هذه الجهه او تلك
انتم بحكم القانون تقومون باصدار امر
القفز وانا المعني بجلبه سواء كان في داخل
العراق او خارجها نتوقع شيء قريب نعم ضد
اسماء كبرى كبرى في هذه السرقه الكبيره
التي تجاوزت على المال موجوده في المشهد
السياسي حاليا قسم والقسم الاخر خارج
المشهد لكن يجب ان يحاسبه ماكو خطوط حمراء
قضيه الفساد قضيه مفصليه هي هي معركه
حقيقيه بس يثيرني للتساؤل دوله الرئيس انه
اذا تكلم عن الحكومات السابقه هي جزء
اليوم من اطار التنسيقي اللي انت جزء منه
وتعبر عنه وبالتالي كانك الان بصدد خوض
معركه مع حلفائك داخل المكون حتى نكون
واضحين اكو فالتعبين بالفساد اكو من يوجه
الفساد لكل الطبقه السياسيه لكل الحكومات
لكل من اشترك في العمليه السياسيه وهذا
خلط هذا غير دقيق اخلط مقصود خلط التفضيع
الامور احسنت هذه كل الناس فاسده
والقسم يراد منه حتى الكل يصاب بالياس
والقنوت وتترك الساحه لطبقه محدده لا
كل رؤساء الحكومات كل الرؤساء البرلمانات
كل الوزراء كل اليوم كلهم موجودين يقول لك
تعال حقق وين ما تلقى فساد تلقى ملف توكل
بالله والقضاء موجود والكل موجود يعني
موافق على هذا يعني احنا شكلنا الحكومه
صار اتفاق سياسي الاتفاق صار على بنود
واحد اثنين ثلاثه واحد من اهم هذه البنوت
قضيه مكافحه الفساد ماكو خطوط حمراء من
اللي متورط يتحاسب يسالني عراقي دوله
الرئيس وعنقلك هذا التساؤل ليش احنا ليش
العراقي فقير مقارنه بدول الخليج بمواطن
الخليجيه والعراقي لديه نفط كما لدول
الخليج نفط ولديه ثروات ليست موجوده لدول
الخليج فلماذا يعني لماذا هذه حاله
الافقار لماذا حاله البطاله حاله الجوع
الشديده في العراق في بلد نفطي ولديه
خيرات توازن النفط ايضا
مغطى بالذهب والفضه بلد محطم احنا عايشين
يعني
الخدمات الاساسيه صفر على مستوى المحافظات
والمدن والاقضيه بعد 2003 خلال هذه
العشرين عام تقول لي ما تنفذ شيء يعني
مستشفى مدرسه جامعه
جسور منشات مشاريع مدن سكنيه موجود ونرجع
وين
للمشاهده العيانيه ما الذي تسبب بانتفاظ
التشريد يعني 2019 الشعب العراقي ما تحقق
لا يوازي الحاجه حاجه كبيره العراق نسبه
النمو الاكثر بدول المنطقه اليوم نتكلم عن
41 مليون ما كانت هذا النفوس اثنين
متطلبات الحياه اختلفت اليوم المواطن يريد
فرص عمل ونحن نتكلم عن فقط المصدر الرئيسي
هو النفط يعني ما عندنا قطاعات اقتصاديه
تستوعب العاطلين عن العمل احنا كان
موظفينا مليون الان موظفين اربعه مليون
و200 مع التغييرات التعيينات الاخيره يمكن
وصلنا خمسه مليون ومع هذا عندنا بطاله
عندنا متقاعدين وصلوا اربعه مليون عندنا
حمايه اجتماعيه نعطيهم اعانات بحدود
المليون وسبعميه اذا الشعب كله عايش على
ما يعطى من الموازنه ما عندنا قطاع خاص
يستوعب البطاله فعدنا بطاله ولهذا الشباب
تشكو عندنا مدن جديده وتريد خدمات اليوم
الشعب يريد له شقه يريد يتزوج يريد يكون
عائلته اقول يعني انا احنا اكو شغل لكنه
مو بالمستوى اللي يغطي احتياجات قصه
الميزانيه دوله الرئيس قريتوها اكثر ثلاثه
اعوام لثلاثه واحده من القرارات المهمه
لهذه الحكومه
قانون الاداره الماليه رقم سته لسنه 2019
الماده اربعه ثانيا تجيز للحكومه تقديم
موازنه لثلاث سنوات السنه الاولى وجوبيها
الثانيه والثالثه يصير فيها نوع من
التعديل ويرجع المجلس النواب هذه شنو
ميزتها اولا تعطي ثبات للاستقرار المالي
ثبات في تنفيذ المشاريع
تمنع المساومات واي حاله ابتزاز تحصل عند
كل عام تنطي رساله للقطاع الخاص انه تعال
اعمل في المدرسه
بس انت ميزانيتك معتمده على سعر النفط
بالتالي هي متغير يتغير الرقم مع تغيير
الاسعار لكن لا حاجه للعوده للبرلمان
والاعتمادات
ترجع اذا صار عندك تغيير لكن اذا كان هناك
ثبات بالاسعار تستمر لماذا خرج رئيس
الوزراء العراقي من اختلاف دوله القانون
وانشات تيارا جديدا تيار
في مشاكل بينك وبين الائتلاف خاصه ان قوه
سياسيه بارزه برئيس المالكيه شخصيه وازنه
دوله القانون كيان مهم وكبير
ويستند على حزب عريق اللي هو حزب الدعوه
الاسلاميه
انا كنت موجود في هذا الكيان الفتره
الماضيه لكن في 2018 وجدت انه ما تقدر انت
تنفذ ما لديك من افكار وكذا
في ظل
وضع سياسي حزبي الى اليات عمله الى تاريخ
العريق
وجدت المرحله مواتيه ان اشكل عنوان سياسي
يضم طيف عراقي يمثل المستقبل وهم الشباب
اللي ما عندهم تجربه سياسي فبدايه التشكيل
مركز دراسات اسميته مركز دراسات الفراتين
ومن خلال هذا المركز واستقطاب الكفاءات
والشخصيات اللي تواجدت معي سواء كان
بالعمل او بحكم الجمهور والعلاقه فاسسنا
نواه لكيان سياسي اسمينا الفراتين ثلاث
ممثلين لديكم في البرلمان بس الان كرئيس
وزراء اذا خطه انتخابات من المتوقع ان هذا
العدد يا سيدي هذا يعتمد على ادائنا متى
ما كان ادائنا مرضي نفذنا اولوياتنا
بالتاكيد فان الشعب سوف يتمسك بهذه
الخيارات ما هي التحديات التي تواجه
المهندس محمد السوداني داخل اطار التنسيقي
الذي يعبر عن القوى الاساسيه الشيعيه
السياسيه في العراق اهم تحديات اهم
القضايا قبل التكليف كان هناك
جلسات ونقاش بيني وبين قوى القيادات قوى
الاطار
واستعرضت امامهم التحديات اللي تواجهنا
وكيف نواجهه
ونتحاور حتى نتفق على
رؤيه
للبرنامج شكل العلاقه
وتناولنا كل القضايا الحساسه ممكن نعرفها
مثلا قضيه اشكاليه السلاح فصائل المسلحه
نعم ووجود التحالف الدولي تعرف المرحله
السابقه كانت مرحله مضطربه ضرب المعسكرات
للسفارات هناك جهات سياسيه موجوده تؤمن
بانه هناك خرق للسياده هناك تواجد غير
شرعي تواجهي بالقوه
فصار حديث انه هذه المواجهه لن تؤدي الى
حلول وقد تؤدي الى وضع غير مستقر
فصار نوع من الاتفاق انه نتعامل مع هذا
الواقع من خلال الحكومه الجديده هي من
تفاوض وتحدد شكل العلاقه مع قوات التحالف
الدولي اللي جاءت في فتره من الفترات
لاسناد العراق في الحرب على داعش هاي
واحده من الاشكاليات المهمه اللي كان
يفترض احسبها انا معه هذه القوه وبالفعل
اعطوني تفويض بانه في حال تكليفك بالحكومه
انت وحكومتك مخول ان تؤدي هذا الدور
وتخرجون باتفاق واضح المعالم
ايش نحتاج من قوات التحالف الدولي مثلا
نحتاج منهم التدريب نتفق هذا البرنامج
التدريبي سنه سنتين ثلاثه نحتاج من عندهم
تبادل المعلومات كيف الاليه واحد اثنين
ثلاثه نحتاج من عندهم
التمكين شنو اليه التمكين بالتسليح بالكذا
وهذه الرؤيه والفصائل المسلحه حدود عملها
اذا اتفقنا على هذه الرؤيه وصارت باتفاق
واضح ومعلن ينتهي بعد دور السلاح عند اي
جهه
ينتهي متى نصل مرحله نزع السلاح بشكل كامل
لانه احنا بدانا هذا واحد من واجبات
الحكومه اللي بداناها ومن خلال نقاشات في
داخل مجلس الامن الوطني بدينا نخوض هذا
الحوار مع التحالف الدولي وهناك افكار سوف
تنضج الى ان تفضي الى اتفاق عندها لن يكون
هناك مبرر لوجود اي سلاح ثانوي غير سلاح
الدوله عبر دمجهم في الاجهزه العسكريه
دمج تسليم السلاح الانتقال الى العمل
المدني المهم ينتهي السلاح وتكون الدوله
ومؤسساتها هي الجهات الوحيده فقط
[موسيقى]
طرح هذه الرؤيه وهي رؤيه محترمه لكنها لم
تؤدي الى نتيجه شنو القرار كان قرار
الانسحاب شوف هذا وهو الفائز الاول انسحب
ولديه قدره حتى حتى الارضيه
والتيار شعبي واضح تغيرت المعادله بحكم
تعويض المستقيلين فرزت هذا
الان التيار الصدري
موجود شعبيه
حزبيا كقوه سياسيه كانت جزء من العمليه
السياسيه طيله الفترات الماضيه فيها كل
الحكومات لا اعتقد انه نوع من الاعتزال
وانما هو اعطى رساله انه كان لديه رغبه ان
يشكل حكومه اغلبيه مو حكومه ائتلافيه تشمل
الجميع ما تمكن في الساحه المجال للاخرين
تفضلوا روح الحكومه
لم تكن عمليه يعني
لكن انتهت سلميا احترموا التداول السلمي
للسلطه مضت الامور الامور بشكل طبيعي في
اطار ويا اداره الدوله
سياده وديمقراطي واتحاد وتوكل والله شكل
الحكومه شكل الحكومه الائتلافيه كلفوا
المتحدث
هنا الاختبار اما ننجح
بتنفيذ برنامجنا واولوياتنا وهذا راح يكون
نوع من المصالحه مع شعبنا لان التحدي الذي
يواجه يواجه الحكومه يواجهنا شخصيا هو كيف
نفسه بثقه المواطن لانه واحد من اهم
الخسرات اللي تعرضت للعمل السياسيه الطبقه
السياسيه الشعب فقد الثقه بالطبقه
السياسيه
[موسيقى]
رغم تعاقب الحكومات بعد الغزو الامريكي
للعراق عام 2003 الا ان بغداد وكردستان لم
تفلحها في طي صفحه الكثير من خلافات
الماضي والحاضر
الملفات والقضايا العالقه بين الجانبين
كثيره ومتشعبه فهي تبدا باشكاليه كركوك
والمناطق المتنازع عليها ولا تنتهي بحصه
الاكراد من الموازنه ومالات ايرادات النفط
والغاز ناهيك عن معضله السلاح والبشمرقه
يمثل الاكراد نحو 15% من سكان العراق
وتاريخيا كانت لديهم امتيازات مقارنه
بنظرائهم المقيمين بالدول المجاوره بين
انهم تعرضوا لقمع شديد بلغ ذروته عام 88
بقصف مدينه حلبجه بالاسلحه الكيمياويه ما
ادى الى سقوط الاف الضحايا
قديما ثار الاكراد في شمال العراق ضد
الانتداب البريطاني ومنذ ذلك الحين حاولوا
مرارا الحصول على الحكم الذاتي استمرت
محاولاتهم حتى عام
1991 عندما قمعت حكومه بغداد انتفاضتهم
بشكل عنيف جدا ما دفع الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها الى فرض منطقه حظر جوي مهدت
الطريقه امام الاكراد لنيل الحكم الذاتي
وفي عام 2003 تعاونت الاحزاب الكرديه
الرئيسيه مع قوات الغزو الامريكي لتشارك
لاحقا في جميع البرلمانات والحكومات التي
شكلت منذ ذلك الحين فيما نص الدستور
الجديد على ان منصب الرئيس العراقي من حصه
الاكراد
دوله الرئيس كنت في اربيل وسليمانيه وفي
اشكاليه معها المكون الكردي دائما حول حول
قضايا عده منها قانون النفط والغاز ما
الذي جرى ماذا يقوم به رئيس الوزراء لجسر
هذه الهوه ولتحقيق مطالب مكون عراقي جزء
من الاتفاق السياسي اللي شكلت على اساس
الحكومه وكان المشاكل العالقه بين بغداد
واربيل واحد من عندها
قضيه النفط والغاز شو التعامل معه وصلنا
الى اتفاق ويتم تضمينه في قانون الموازنه
وهو جزء من الاتفاق الاساسي
واعطينا سقف زمني سته اشهر
راح نتاخر شويه على السته اشهر حتى تنشر
قانون النفط والغاز اللي ينظم العلاقه
بشكل
باي شكل وباي اتجاه ستنظم العلاقه وفق
التشريع التشريع قانون ماذا يحتوي يعني
حقول المكتشفه بعد 2003 لان هذا نص عليها
الدستور فيها هامش لاداره
مو فقط الاقليم حتى المحافظات يعني هو
البعض يعتقد انه القضيه النفط والغاز فقط
بين الاتحاد
الاتحاديه في حين انه كثير محافظات تريد
دورها في هذا القانون باعتبار الاقليم ملف
النفط قال هناك يعني هناك عدم كفاءه في
دارته وهناك فساد ايضا وهناك امور كثيره
الاقليم الطرد للذهاب الى عقود فيها نوع
من الاذعان وصلت الى حد ابتزاز من الشركات
امتزت الاقليم في فتره 2014 عندما كان
هناك حرب على داعش وعندما توقفت الموازنه
للاقليم فاضطرت الاقليم امام استحقاقات
المعركه وامام نزوح الملايين هذا كله سبب
ضغط على الخدمات ان يذهب بعقود في هذا
الغبن الواضح واستمر
بتمشيه الامور رغم انها كانت صعبه ولا
زالت على ابناء شعبنا في اقليم كردستان
تعرف رواتب واستحقاقات وغيرها من شان هذا
الاتفاق على قانون الموازنه ان ينهي هذه
المشاكل ان تكون موازنه شامله لكل
العراقيين وبنفس الوقت نتهيا لتشريع هذا
القانون قانون النفطور الغاز ماذا عن مكون
السنه لديه مطالب وتحدثت ربما اكثر من مره
اعانوا وجوب تحقيق مطالب كافه المكونات ما
الذي يريده سنه العراق والذي لم يتحقق من
هو الذي يمكن ان يتحقق في عهدكم والله مو
مط مستحيله او مستحصيه او غير قابله
بالعكس استحقاقات مواطنين وحقوق شنو ابرز
هذول كان يفترض ان تنجز قبل سنوات يعني
تتصور
صار مطلب هذا انه التدقيق الامني في
المناطق المحرره هذا اسلوب لجات للاجهزه
الامنيه بعد التحرير لانه قسم من الدواعش
يرجعون مع المواطنين يتواجدون في المدن
فاكو فداه تدقيق لكن بقت هذه الاليه سنوات
وتستخدم مرات بشكل متاسف فساد بيها تعطيل
فدرسناها لقينا هذا الاليه
اكو قوانين اخرى يراد لها تعديل واحد
القانون
في المساله والعداله يعني مو تعديل هو وفق
رقم عشره لسنه 2008 الماده 25 بعد اكمال
للمهام الهيئه تقدم تقريرها المجلس
النوابه وحل
قانون الخاص
بالمفقودين
عوده النازحين هذه كلها استحقاقات يعني
واجبه ومطلوبه من الدوله هل تمت الشيشه
سيتحقق او شيء يعني ملح على جدول
اولوياتكم اكيد
نحن
شكلنا لجنه حكومه لتنفيذ التزاماتنا
التزامات الحكومه المثبته في
اتفاق السياسي لغايه اليوم وصلنا الى نسبه
تنفيذ واحد وثلاثين بالمئه وهذه نتحدث في
الخمسه اشهر هذا يعكس جديه الحكومه لتنفيذ
الالتزامات وهذا جزء من بناء الثقه
تنتظرنا انتخابات مبكره دوله الرئيس
نحن نعد العده لاقامه انتخابات محليه على
مستوى مجالس
مهم جدا ان تكون المحافظات ابناء
المحافظات شركاء في اداره محافظاتهم ثم
الحكومه جاهزه لاي انتخابات مبكره او
دوريه تعرف الانتخابات المبكره حضرتك لازم
البرلماني يحل نفسه وهذا قرار البرلمان مو
حكومه مو الحكومه
تاريخ حافل من التقلبات السياسيه
والتحديات العسكريه والتجاذبات العقائديه
هكذا يمكن اختصار العلاقه المعقده بين
العراق وايران شكل عام 79 محطه مفصليه
بتاريخ البلدين ففيه قامت الثوره
الاسلاميه في طهران وفيه ايضا تولى صدام
حسين مقاليد السلطه في بغداد وقبل ان
تستقر الاوضاع لنظامي الحكم الجديدين دخلت
العلاقات بين الدولتين منزلقا خطيرا مع
اتهام ايران العراق باعدام الرموز الشيعيه
المعارضه واتهام الثانيه للاولى باستغلال
المذهب الشيعي لتصدير الثوره الى الدول
المجاوره سرعان ما تحول التراشق الاعلامي
الى فوهه المدافع نتيجه الخلاف على حقيه
المياه في شط العرب ليبدا البلدان عام 80
اطول حروب القرن العشرين في المنطقه حرب
دام الثمانيه اعوام وخلفت اكثر من مليون
قتيل
وضعت الحرب اوزارها لكن بين الجارين
اللدودين لم تتحسن وبعد ذلك بعامين خاض
العراق مغامره غزو الكويت التي انتهت
باخراجه منها مهزوما على يد قوات دوليه
اثناء الحصار الدولي على العراق استمرت
الخلافات قائمه بين البلدين حتى العام
2003 عندما غزت واشنطن وحلفائها العراق في
البدايه اعلن الطهران معارضه الحرب ومن ثم
وقوفها على الحياد قبل ان تبدي فرحتها
العارمه بسقوط نظام صدام حسين عقب الغزو
الامريكي دخلت العلاقه بين الدولتين مرحله
جديده لم تقتصر على تعزيز العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه وانما بات الطهران وفق ما يرى
الكثيرون اللاعب الاقوى داخل الساحه
العراقيه
ماذا يريد الايرانيون تحدثتم ظهرت اخبار
عن اتفاقيه وعن حديث ايران رغبتها بان
تضبط بغداد تتحمل مسؤوليتها الفصائل
المسلحه الكرديه التي تقوم بنشاطات عسكريه
في ايران هذه واحده من الاشكاليات اللي
اثرت على الوضع الامني في الحدود
بسبب وجود
الاحزاب المعارضه
الايرانيه واللي موجوده بصفه لاجئين منذ
سنوات في اقليم كردستان من زمن النظام
السابق
لكن وجودهم كلاجئين امر طبيعي اما وجودهم
كمسلحين
ومعسكرات واعداد وتدريب ودخول الى داخل
الاراضي الايرانيه والقيام باعمال مسلحه
ورجوع الى العراق عدم في مشكله اولا
دستورنا يمنع واضح الدستور العراقيه يمنع
ان تكون الارض العراقيه منطلقا للقيام
باعمال العدائيه ضد الاخرين اثنين كون
نضمن نضمن امن حدودنا ولا ما معقوله
حدودنا مفتوحه وتكون هذه العمليات هذه ادى
الى انه الجانب الايراني بدا يقوم بعمليات
على هذه المعسكرات وهذه الاماكن وهذا ايضا
هم خطا
يعني ضرب ضرب
هذا التجاوز تجاوز على السياده العراقيه
يؤثر على مستوى العلاقه اللي بين العراق
وايران اللي هي مبنيه على كثير من
المشتركات هو ناصر للتفاهم
عقدنا سلسله اجتماعات واجراءات على مستوى
مجلس الامن الوطني على مستوى اللجان
المشتركه بيننا وبين ايران بناء على
زيارتي الى طهران قبل ثلاثه اشهر وصلنا
الى هذا الاتفاق يوم تم توقيعه والذي يلزم
بمسك الحدود تسليم المطلوبين ومنع
المعسكرات وباقي التفاصيل نامل ان يكون
هذا الاتفاق يعني عامل
استقرار وامن للحدود
الحكومه المركزيه اما مسؤوليه الحكومه
الحكومه اقليم كردستان الحكومه الاتحاديه
وحكومه اقليم كردستان معنيه بتنفيذ هذا
الاتفاق في مجلس الامن الوطني كان موجود
البيش وناقشنا هذا الاتفاق وحكومه الاقليم
ايضا ناقشت وحظيه باتفاق الجميع يدفعني
هذا الحديث عن العلاقات العراقيه
الايرانيه العراق ايران لاعب رئيسي كان
اللاعب الرئيسي هو ولايه المتحده هل ما
زالت الايران هي المؤثر الاكبر في المشهد
السياسي العراقي
ايران دوله جاره نرتبط معاها
بمشتركات دينيه اجتماعيه ثقافيه نعمه
العمليه السياسيه بعد 2003 بشكل واضح
بحكم المعارضه كانت موجوده في ايران
الاحزاب مقربه عن سوريا وكذا علاقاتها
طيبه مع كل المكونات مو فقط المكون شيعي
للامانه
هذا الوصف هذا علاقه ايجابيه
اما مساله تدخل فاكيد هذا مرفوض ما حجم
التدخلات الايرانيه كانت في السياسه
العراق اي تدخل انا اليوم من اتحدث وانا
رئيس حكومه من مراحل تشكيل الحكومه
مفاوضاتها العسيره
وصولا الى الكابينه وكذا ما شفت ولا
صادفني موقف في تدخل او وصايه او فرض
لا هو مقبول اصلا
ولا هو موجود بصراحه في نوع من المبالغه
بس اسم ايران حتى في التظاهرات الشيعيه
كان اسمي ايران هذا جزء من
استاذ احنا مشكلتنا دائما نقول
ما نريد العراق ساحه لتصفيه الحسابات
مشاكل بينها وبين الولايات المتحده اكو
كان
سوء تفاهم او تقاطع مع بعض دول الخليج
فمساله ان ينعكس هذا الامر على الواقع
العراقي تصفيه حسابات هذا مرفوض احنا
بالنسبه لنا ما احد يزايد على استقلاليه
قرارنا الوطني ابدا
لا ايران ولا امريكا ولا غيرها العراق هو
من طبعه نفسه عزيزه وانفه ما يقبل وصايا
انتقلت الحاله من حاله حرب عراقيه ايرانيه
استمرت ثمان سنوات سقط فيها مليون شهيد
عراقي ليسوا من مكون واحد من مكونات كافه
ثم الى حاله يعني وصفت كانها والتبعيه في
المرحله الاولى ثم محاولات لخلق نديه
اليوم او توازن بين الطرفين فهي العلاقه
الايرانيه العراقيه اشكاليه دائما
انا تقديري التوصيف يتبع
وضع المنطقه والتجاذبات والصراعات
لم يكن ولن يكون العراق في يوم ما تابع
لاحد
لا للشرق ولا للغرق هذا واحد
ومثل ما ذكرت واكد هناك
استقلاليه في القرار الوطني
وسياده هذا القرار تجاه اي جهه خارجيه
احنا عندنا حساسيه العراقيه من واحد يفرض
علينا او يتدخل
هذا هذا جانب اكو علاقه ايجابيه نعم اكو
علاقه ايجابيه وهذه العلاقه الايجابيه
طبيعيه مع ايران ومع غيرها لماذا لا تكون
علاقتكم علاقتكم العربيه مع السعوديه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه على وجه التحديد
موازيه للعلاقه مثلا مع ايران في كل مراحل
العمليه السياسيه كان اول زياره يقوم بها
رئيس وزراء يزور السعوديه
ايمانا من بدور السعوديه دورها على
المستوى
الدول الاسلاميه والمنطقه وثقلها
والمشتركات اللي
كل دول العربيه السعوديه نعم شنو سمعت
هناك وشنو قلت والله يعني عهد جديد
نفس اللي سمعته من ذكرته انا الاخ ولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان قلت له اتذكر
انا تحدثت واحد اثنين ثلاثه جنابك في
زيارتنا للسعوديه عام 2017
مع دكتور حيدر العبادي يعني كنت وزير
قلت له في حينها اتذكر كلمتك قلت له يا
دكتور حيدر دوله الرئيس اني وزرائي
مستشارين عندك
رجل قال لي قال لي واليوم انا وزرائي
وعندي استعداد يا اخي السوداني عد استعداد
استثمر بالعراق من المليار للمئه مليار
دولار
تصريح ولي العهد السعودي
وهذا على اساس صارت زيارات
تفاوض سعوديه ايرانيه في العراق و العراق
بدعم وبوساطه عراقيه بس تفاجانا الاتفاق
وقع في الصين ليش ما صار في بغداد هذه
بركات الجولات الخمسه ما اثر هذا الاتفاق
السعودي على العراق مهم جدا كان واحد من
الملفات اللي يقوم فيها العراق على
التقريب بين السعوديه وايران
ايمانا منهم باهميه وجود هذا التفاهم بين
دولتين مهمتين في المنطقه قطعا سوف يسهم
في استقرار وامن المنطقه اليوم احنا كنا
نتكلم عن تنميه واقتصاد والتنميه
والاقتصاد لا يمكن ان تكون الا في اجواء
الاستقرار والتفاهم والتعاون بين دول
الهجمات التي تعرضت لها السعوديه ومنشات
النفطيه في السعوديه هذا ليس حديثا رسميا
لكن قيل ان مصادرها العراق هل يكون العراق
وسيبقى العراق مصدرا لاي اذى تتعرض له
السعوديه ودول الخليج اي اعتداء على اي
دوله السعوديه او اي دوله هو امر مرفوض
هذه قضيه دستوريه نحن لا نسمح ان يتم
الاعتداء استخدام الارض العراقيه منطلق
لاعتداء على دول الجوار هذا درس دستور لا
يلزمنا كحكومه وبنفس الوقت مصلحتنا ايضا
والتزامنا الاخلاقي تجاه الاشقانا
وجيراننا لا يمكن للعراق ان يقبل الاعتداء
الاخرين
هذه مساله محسومه وبالتاكيد لن نتفرج على
اي حاله اعتدال حتى لا نبتعد كثيرا عن
الدول الخليج الكويت متى ترسمون الحدود
البحريه مع الكويت انا دائما اشكاليه بعد
عام 90 وغزو العراق من الكويت تحتاج الى
حسم لهذا الملف راح تاخد قطاع الشوط
الاكبر من التفاهمات في كل الملفات
بقيه هناك
ملف الحدود البحريه
لجان عقده اجتماعها مؤخرا في بغداد اللجنه
القانونيه واللجنه الفنيه
والعراق جاد بازاله كل العوائق التي تعترض
سير العلاقه بين العراق والكويت والكويت
دوله الشقيقه ايضا كانت جزء من ضحايا
النظام السابق و يهمنا
نتجاوز اثار الماضي وننطلق بما لدينا من
فرص وافاق تساهم في تعزيز العلاقه بين
البلدين الشقيقين عنا مشكله من مبارك ومن
ام قصر يسعد جميع يعني واضح انه اكثر من
مره يتم التصعيد
ربما تفجر خلافات اقصد لا لا ابدا من
مبارك موجود في المياه الدوليه بالحدود
الرسميه لدوله الكويت بناء وايضا مياهنا
وحدودنا الرسميه والدوليه
وممكن هم ينشؤون منها واحنا ماضيين في
انشاء
اذا ما تحدثنا عن تركيا وتركيا ايضا بلد
رئيسي تربطه مع العراق علاقات مهمه وايضا
جوانب حدوديه وتركيا تقوم بعمليات عسكريه
في المناطق مناطق الاقليم مواجهه حزب
العمال الكردستانيه الذي يعني تصنفه عدوا
لها
وهناك اشكاليات لها علاقه بالقضايا
المائيه
والعراق مستورد كبير جدا ايضا لكثير من
فكيف طبيعه العلاقه مع تركيا تركيا دوله
جاره وايضا في من المشتركات الكثيره دينيه
اجتماعيه ثقافيه في مصالح نعم اكو مشاكل
الامن المياه لكن ما موجود من فرص هو اكبر
من هذه المشاكل
نحن
متوجهون نحو تركيا لاقامه شراء اقتصاديه
وهناك مشاريع استراتيجيه سوف ترى النور
قريبا جدا ان شاء الله
تعزز من هذه العلاقه
وتعود بالفائده على الشعبين الجارين
المياه هناك جهود مشكوره من تركيا لتامين
الحصص المائيه للعراق وهذه تعرف واعراف
واتفاقيات دوليه الدول المتشابه مطلوب
منها ان تحافظ على
اطلاقات المائيه بما يؤمن احتياجاتنا من
جانبنا ايضا يحتاج لنا اداره مثله للمياه
في ظل التطور الكبير اليوم في استخدام
التقنيات الحديثه على مستوى الامن واضح
جدا نفس الاشكاليه اللي صارت مع الجار
ايران ايضا عندنا هذه نفس هذه الاتفاقيه
مع تركيا
الان تعمل للوصول الى اتفاق ينظم العلاقه
وينظم كيفيه سيطرتنا على الحدود بشكل
حقيقي
بالمبررات اللي يقدموها هذا مو تبرير
للطلبات
الايرانيه والتركيه يقول احنا الحدود
مفتوحه ماكو قوات اتحاديه متواجده ماسكه
الحدود حتى نتمكن من تامينها تفاهمنا مع
الاخوه الاقليم كردستان انه يجب ان تتواجد
قوات اتحاديه على طول للحدود العراقيه
التركيه والعراقيه الايرانيه حتى لا تسمح
حتى لا تسمع عمليات عسكريه ولا ايرانيه
وانتم بصدد هذا نعم
وزاره الداخليه لتطوير 3000 من حرس الحدود
والاجراءات مستمره نظام السوري يبدو انه
يعود شيئا فشيئا موقف العراق الرسمي من
هذه القضيه المطروحه اليوم على الساحه
السياسيه من عوده سوريا والعلاقات
المباشره لابد من عدد سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه
لا يمكن ان يبقى الوضع كما هو عليه سوريا
الان تتعرض الى مشاكل حقيقيه المستوى
الاقتصادي المعيشي وخصوصا بعد
حادثه الزلزال الاخير واثار الكارثيه على
الشعب السوري سوريا عانت وانا الاوان ان
يتم التعامل مع النظام الرسمي الموجود
الدوله الموجوده نظام قسم الذي يدير هذه
الدوله وان يتم استخدام لغه الحوار بدلا
من الحصار والقطيعه التي لن سوى الشعب
مهما كان مرتكبه من يعني فضائح في حق شعب
هذه تترك السياقاتها وهذا حوار ممكن يقام
في داخل سوريا بين نظام سياسي بين قوى
المعارضه بدون تدخل لم تجني سوريا ولا
المنطقه من التدخلات الخارجيه سوى مزيد من
الدماء والماسي من 2011 واحنا نتكلم عن
الجرائم والكذا والتدخلات
والتشكيلات وانتهينا نتكلم عن حوار كان من
الممكن انه نذهب للحوار من البدايه بدلا
ما
الغريب انه في في وقت في بدايات يعني ما
بعد 2003 كان العراق يتهم سوريا يتهم بشار
الاسد دمشق تحديدا بالسماح للمقاتلين
والانتحارين وكان تحديدا النوري المالكي
يتحدث عن نظام السوري ثم بعد الثوره
السوريه 2011 مباشره وقف العراق عبر
رسميا لماذا لدعم لماذا لان البديل داعش
انت تخيل طب هو المسؤول عن داعش مكان
مسؤول عن داعش داعش وهو اللي جابها لا في
العمليات التي كانت تتم في العراق كان
الاتهام لسوريا ان هي من تسهل لا فرق بين
داعش واكو عصابات كانت او جهات تدعي
المقاومه او القاعده او ما شاف كان هناك
نشاط اشرت الحكومه العراقيه في حينها
وكانت محقه يعني من نكرها اشكلنا على
الاشقاء في
سوريا ان هناك خرق وتسبب في دخول
الانتحاريه واللي ثبتنا وجودهم في اكثر من
لكن عندما تطور الامر الى وج
هذا الكيان الارهابي
القاتل يتواجد على حدودك فتخيل انت وضعك
شلون الان اذا تسالني انا قائد عامل
للقوات المسلحه شنو هي التحديات
اخطر التحديات الامنيه التي تواجهني هو
الوضع الامني في سوريا هناك سجون فيها
عتات الارهابيين الدواعش وهناك معسكرات
ومخيمات اي حاله ارتباك امني هؤلاء سوف
يكونون على الحدود العراق تم العراق مع
العراق فمن مصلحتي من مصلحه امن العراق
فضلا عن امن الاردن ولبنان وسوريا ان يتم
التعامل مع هذه
السؤال الاخير سيد رئيس الوزراء انت قلت
انه يجب علينا اعاده تعريف الوجود
الامريكي في العراق وهذه مساله في غايه
الاهميه الولايات المتحده احتلت العراق في
2003 اسقطت نظام واوجدت نظاما جديدا
واستمرت باحتلاله فتره طويله ثم تم
الاتفاق على
باي اتجاه نعرف الوجود الامريكي اليوم
الحكومه العراقيه في 2014 طلبت بشكل رسمي
من مجلس الامن دعم العراق في مواجهه
الارهاب
على ضوء الطلب الرسمي من العراق
اتخذ المجلس الامن القرار بتشكيل تحالف
دولي تقوده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لدعم جهود العراقي مكافحه الارهاب وصار
هذا التحالف الدولي وبدت عمليات تحرير
الان انتهينا من داعش مثل ما ذكرت لك ماكو
شيء اسمه داعش الان مجاميع نطاردها في
الكهوف والجبال والصحراء قواتنا الامنيه
قادره وعلى درجه من الجهوزيه والامكانيه
ان توفر الامن في كل ارجاء العراق بدون اي
تردد
اذا احنا ما نحتاج قوات قتاليه وبالتالي
ما نحتاج الى تواجد اجنبي نحتاج الى
علاقات امنيه نحن بنحتاج الى علاقه نحتاج
الى تعاون الى تدريب تبادل المعلومات نعم
هذا ايراد للسياق جديد ايراد لتعريف تثبيت
بشكل رسمي حتى يكون واضح ان لشعبنا
للجهات التي ترى ان هناك وجود امريكي يمس
السياده هذا حق طبيعي الاصدقاء في
الولايات المتحده متفهمون لهذا الطلب
ويمكن
الدفاع الرئيس
دعوه من الحكومه العراقيه
في تصريح وزير الدفاع احنا موجودين حتى ما
بعد داعش نعم باراده الحكومه العراقيه
يعني
وجود قطع احنا ما طالبين من وجهه قتالي ما
نحتاج
اليوم
التواجد هذا نحاول ان نعمل على تنظيمه وفق
الصيغه اللي تكلمنا فيها بصيغه تفاهم
رسميه واضحه للتعاون الثنائي مع الولايات
المتحده بيننا وبين الولايات المتحده
اتفاقيه
الاطار استراتيجي فيها التعاون الامني
والاقتصادي والتكنولوجي والثقافي والعلمي
وهذا هو جزء من نظرتنا الى الولايات
المتحده كشريك استراتيجي دوله عظمى تربط
العراق علاقه صداقه ومن مصلحتنا نفتح افاق
بالتعاون في هذه المجالات وان لا يقتصر
الوجود فقط على الوجود الامني دوله الرئيس
المهندس محمد شيعه السوداني رئيس الوزراء
العراقي انا ممتن جدا شاكر لك تحت هذه
الفرصه والوقت الطويل
لحلقتين من المقابله واتسع صدرك حديثنا
واعتقد انه حديث في غايه الاهميه للشعب
العراقي ولي ايضا جمهورنا العربي الواسع
في كل مكان لمعرفه ماذا يجري في العراق
شاكر ومقدر شكرا جزيلا لكم شكرا وصل لكم
مشاهدينا الكرام على طيب المتابعه دمتم
بخير القاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع المقبل
في حلقه جديده في امان الله
[موسيقى]